[Music]
different places many races
living in the sun
according to advertisers like coffee
maker greg's 1970s new zealand
was a harmonious utopia
and so 150 years on the great great
granddaughter of queen victoria
arrived in waitangi escorted by a
thousand warriors
in these magnificent long walk news
and while the country has long been
lauded for its integration
and tolerance not everyone shared such a
rosy view
in the background the shouts and yells
of maori activist protesters
as they try to get closer to the queen
colonised by the british in the 19th
century the indigenous population
the maori would lose 97 of their land
often through deception and violence
maori have been disadvantaged ever since
we
have horrific health statistics
education statistics
we are 17 of the population
but make up 52 of the prison population
something had to be done to mitigate
the horrific atrocities that have been
committed
a reparations program was created to
reconcile the wrongs of the past
and formalize settlement agreements
between the state and the maori people
[Music]
settlement processes have contributed
to empowering maori in a big way
we're relatively now a wealthy um
tribe with net settlement assets of
close to
1.6 billion and rising
they've been able to give them an
economic opportunity
to start developing something that we
would never been able to before
so are new zealand settlement agreements
an example of how best to tackle
historical grievances
there are no easy answers in the search
for that elusive concept known as
justice
so long after the event
the islands in the southwest pacific now
known as new zealand
were once inhabited only by the maori
they formed tribes and sub-tribes known
as ewi and harpu
as the tentacles of western imperialism
spread around the world in the 18th
century white settlers landed in what
was then called
our tiara looking for resources to
exploit
by the start of the 19th century it was
like the wild west
a lot of them were sealers and whalers
it was just
debauchery all over the place
drunkenness
murder every non-civilized behavior
was there our ancestors became
increasingly frustrated that they
could not get these people to abide by
the laws of the country
in 1840 the british made an agreement
with over 500 maori chiefs that would
forever define their relationship
the treaty of waitangi the treaty that
was entered into in 1840
was to give over responsibility from
our leaders here to the british leader
who at that time was queen victoria in
addition
maori chiefs thought the treaty would
give them more say on trade and land
sales
but the language of the treaty is
contentious
two versions one maori one english
didn't help the maori copy promised they
would continue to own their
lands forests and fisheries the english
version gave the queen
all the rights and powers of sovereignty
over their land
in the maori language there isn't a
direct translation for the word
sovereignty
because there was no singular ruler over
the land
the british government insisted the
treaty placed the maori under british
authority
in our culture if you want to include
people in the culture
you give them over land so that they
will become part of you
well the british misinterpreted that
as being that we had sold our lands to
them and given everything
up which simply just wasn't true there
was a great deal of land
initially for settlement and the crown
acquired it mostly through purchasing
but the purchasers were forced
purchasers basically
and the the promises made to maori
were um essentially broken
and then when that land started to run
out then the crown
invaded areas that were resisting
so essentially we have typical
colonization
procedures to alienate maori land
and to marginalize maori culture
and to try and assimilate maori into the
western ways of
thinking and seeing and doing
wars western diseases poverty
the effects of colonization decimated
the maori population
estimates suggest there might have been
a hundred thousand maori by the end of
the 18th century
the 1896 census counted just 42 000.
within a generation the maori went from
being landlords for the white settlers
to being their labourers and all at the
hands of their own government it wasn't
just
resources that they took office they
tried to destroy us
as well as a people take away our
language take away our culture
write legislation making them illegal
not allowed to be taught in schools
my father and his generation were all
physically
punished and psychologically punished if
they spoke maori
in schools that's one of the reasons
that we have such difficulty in shifting
the status quo is that the british came
out here
to seek their fortune in a land that was
not their own
um and in the process of doing so became
very privileged very wealthy very
powerful
and are not prepared to give that up
new zealand used to pride itself on
being
the country with the best race relations
in the world
and from about the 1960s 1970s onwards
people increasingly challenged that
after the second world war
maori began to migrate to the cities in
search of employment
and modern life the speed of this
transformation highlighted the gulf
between the two sets of people
maori experienced discrimination in
housing and employment
were expected to learn english and
abandon their customs
but this new generation of urban maori
would have a huge impact
marty in the cities had much more
capacity to challenge the crown and to
get the crown to actually listen to
their grievances
particularly younger maori who were
educated
and knew how to make their way in the
white world the pakia world
young maori were terribly influenced by
the the
protest movements right around the world
in the 1960s
including black power in america the
um american indian movement but then the
maori landmark
in 1975 that was tremendously important
to bringing
maori issues to pakistan and that was a
combination of elders
led by a very revered queer female elder
uh then fina cooper um and and
an association with a lot of younger
more radical people
suffering with arthritis 80 year old
fina cooper led 5000 people on a 700
mile march
to protest stolen maori land
this period of cultural and political
revival is now known as the maori
renaissance
it helped unify maori opinion on land
reclamation
and it opened the eyes of white new
zealanders to maori causes
and race more broadly you started
getting some sort of
understanding amongst the general
population that things weren't all that
good for maori and maybe that did
explain why maori were
so poor and and so
not able to keep up with the rest of the
country
but there was no understanding of how
deliberate
and how the the bad faith that was
involved
in what the british did was simply not
there
the same year as the land march the new
zealand government launched the waitangi
tribunal to investigate contemporary
breaches of the 1840 treaty
maori culture was being revitalized and
better protected
huge numbers of new zealanders also
protested the visit of the south african
rugby team
who maintained the segregationist policy
of apartheid
as both national and international
attention increased
the new zealand government amended the
treaty of waitangi act
to investigate historical grievances
dating back to the treaty of 1840
they began to realize that if you have a
large
indigenous population that's
dissatisfied with
fundamental aspects of the way you're
running the country
and the way you have run it then the
only way
forward in a meaningful way is to
address their grievances
by 1985 the tribunal was hearing claims
from individual tribes and started
making settlements varying in size and
substance
and offering more than just monetary
compensation
some included formal apologies from the
crown the apology was tremendously
important for maori
and the initial tribes we negotiated
with
they insisted on an apology and the
crown was incredibly reluctant to do so
they probably thought well they
certainly thought that there might
be legal ramifications for that some
claims had cultural significance
such as the restoration of maori names
of geographical features
one ewe had so much economic success
resulting from its settlement agreement
that it became a blueprint for others to
follow the nighter who
lost economic loss was valued at 20
billion
20 billion and we settled on the cash
offer of the 170 million
the naitahu land in the south island
which is equivalent in size to the state
of new york
was taken by the british for just 14 750
pounds
our people were split there were those
who
who did not want to settle
because the the quantum
the value that we were settling for was
significantly
less than what the assessment of what
the value should have been
[Music]
despite the discrepancy and value the
night our who have built a successful
portfolio
and intergenerational wealth through
savvy investment
as of may 2019 naita whose fund boasts
an average annual return
of more than 15 percent according to the
ewe's investment arm we're relatively
now
a wealthy tribe with net settlement
assets of close to
1.6 billion today naita who has
interests in
fishing tourism property as well as a
diversified
[Music]
equities portfolio all of which are
managed
through our nato holdings
limited our commercial company
structurally there are
two parts to the organization so we have
one arm that makes the money
and we have another arm that spends the
money and we keep them very separate
the settlement at that time was a relief
for our people it meant that our
grievances were acknowledged it meant
the wrongdoings of the crown were
acknowledged
it meant that we could finally have
redress
that could assist us to develop a strong
economic base to support our people and
for our elders
the apology part of settlement meant
that they
felt that our tupuna our ancestors
before us
the wrong doings had been acknowledged
today
we are strong enough and honest enough
to learn the lessons of the last 150
years
and to admit that the treaty has been
imperfectly observed
despite wide acceptance of the need for
settlement agreements
the process is found wanting from both
sides of the divide
some criticize the increasing number of
claims and expense
many maori argue settlements don't even
begin to scratch the surface of their
losses the amount that they were
offering
to settle these claims was minuscule you
know i'm talking one percent
of of what was lost and no consideration
at all for the social
socioeconomic damage that had been been
done
the grinding poverty and the grinding
marginalization deprivation just became
too much for our people and so they
started accepting
just a little bit to get themselves up
off
the grinding poverty and once they
started doing that the government
machine was relentless and it just
drove settlements and i was one of the
negotiators
my my ewe decided we would try
to see if we could get our lands back
and under the settlement process
it was the most horrific demoralizing
um process that i've ever been through
they would come into your ewe divide
your ewe so that you're all fighting
each other and that was the biggest
damage that was done
was the internal conflict that it caused
and all of that for the return of one
percent
of your land settling is also
contentious for some maori who aspire to
rangatiratanga which translates as the
right of maori people to rule themselves
another issue was how the crown could
give away land
owners of private land who gained it
through legal means cannot have it taken
from them
the crown can only give its own land or
money for the tribes to purchase land
it had to offer packages that could
never fully compensate the tribes
but were large enough to help them
rebuild
they also had to be kept in line with
the other tribes of which
there are around a hundred some of you
aren't close to settling either
the claims process is far from perfect
and will always attract conflicting
views
but what the majority agree is that it
offers a road map
on how to acknowledge events of the past
and build for the future
what extends beyond the negotiating
table
that is not the end of our relationship
nor is it the end of the crown's
responsibility
it's the fact that not everyone has a
decent home
a decent place to live and
it's the incarceration of the maori
people
disproportionately to everyone else that
is the distance between us
and so long as that exists we have
failed in our partnership
but i inherently believe in our power to
change
i look back to the time before
previous seven months when maori
were in despair of getting anything much
at all out of the crown any kind of
respect for
rangatiratanga and where
pakia thought that we had
perfect race relations there wasn't much
of a problem
i think most new zealanders of european
descent
wouldn't think that now at all they
know that there was a typical colonial
past for new zealand
and that maori were disenfranchised and
disadvantaged and marginalized
while systemic issues remain in new
zealand settlements have revitalized
communities
increased intergenerational wealth and
reconcile differences
the maori economy is now worth almost 70
billion new zealand dollars
that's up from an estimated 50 billion
in 2013.
i don't want to kind of leave it with
too rosy a view
but i do think that we have made
enormous
progress and we're on quite a good
platform
for better progress still
you